Super.
Nous sommes devant la doctrine de la création.
Depuis déjà quelques semaines, on s'est approfondi plutôt sur les premières choses qui ont été créées,
donc les premiers êtres personnels, les anges.
Et on a considéré les anges comme les premiers actes de création des dieux.
Et ensuite, la création du cosmos.
Donc la création de l'univers visible.
Et c'est là où nous sommes en train de considérer cette réalité.
Et on sait très bien, comme on a vu depuis la semaine dernière,
que la question à propos de l'origine de toutes les choses n'est pas une question posée par la religion ou pour les croyants,
mais c'est une question exploitée par la philosophie et par la science aussi.
Donc notre objectif principal, et c'est là où la valeur des premiers leçons de la confession des frases,
c'est-à-dire à propos des écritures, sont très importantes pour nous, les croyants,
pour nous rappeler que nous sommes devant un livre inspiré, un livre qui ne peut pas avoir tort.
Et tout ce qu'il parle, tout ce qu'il présente est la vérité pour nous.
Quand on est devant les points de divergence possibles devant la Bible,
il faut qu'on soit sûr, car un des attributs, ça c'est important de rappeler,
un des attributs des écritures, c'est sa clarté.
Et donc pour douter d'un enseignement clair des écritures,
il faut qu'on soit convaincu, pleinement convaincu, honnêtement convaincu,
qu'un enseignement n'est pas si clair.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Donc si nous doutons du récit, de la lecture naturelle par exemple,
du témoignage biblique à propos de la création,
c'est-à-dire surtout Genèse, chapitre 1,
si on doute qu'il s'agisse d'un texte littéral, historique,
il faut qu'on soit pleinement convaincu,
et même bibliquement convaincu,
que nous pouvons avoir des flexibilités d'interprétation sur ces textes.
Et donc c'est important pour nous de nous approcher du texte biblique
en nous rappelant de ce qu'on a déjà étudié et appris
dans la confession de foi à propos des écritures.
Et donc, nous approcher de la Genèse,
pour nous notre intérêt principal,
comme nous avons les points d'avantage d'avoir la Bible de notre côté,
c'est d'avoir cette assurance
que celui qui a créé toutes les choses nous a donné un témoin.
Il nous a expliqué, il l'a mentionné.
Il n'a pas donné des informations exhaustives
par rapport à comment, dans tous les détails scientifiques,
la terre a été créée,
mais ce que la Bible dit à propos de la création est vrai.
Et donc la réalité, c'est que nous devons nous approcher avant tout
de ces thèmes par des considérations bibliques,
nous en tant que croyants.
Mais c'est important de nous rappeler des sévérités,
d'être ancrés dans les écritures,
car dans les dernières générations,
il y a eu la popularisation d'une théorie
par rapport à l'origine de l'univers,
notamment la théorie de l'évolution,
qui a eu, par sa popularisation,
un impact dans l'Église
et a conduit des générations des chrétiens
à chercher à faire une nouvelle lecture
et interprétation des Genèses.
Et j'ai dit nouvelle,
car ça contredit la plupart majoritaires,
largement majoritaires,
d'interprétations bibliques de ces textes
comme historiques et littérales.
Et la réalité, c'est que cet impact-là
a des restes jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Même dans les meilleures Églises,
nous pouvons voir comment,
à partir du moment où on étudie la création
ou l'origine de l'univers,
on a des attentes déjà automatiques
de vouloir écouter
de la part d'une autorité étrangère à la Bible,
c'est-à-dire l'autorité de la science,
qui réclame avoir une autorité pour la connaissance,
à propos d'un sujet qui ne peut pas être défini
à la base comme science.
Je vais vous expliquer,
je vais vous faire ces rappels,
mais la réalité, c'est qu'à partir du moment
où on va traiter la création,
les premiers grands rappels qu'on doit avoir,
c'est ce qu'on a fait la semaine dernière,
c'est que l'autorité suprême et suffisance
pour nous parler à propos de la création,
c'est la Bible et non la science.
La science, elle peut renforcer ou non les théories,
mais la réalité, c'est que ce que la Bible nous présente
est la source ultime,
elle devrait être pour nous la source suffisante.
Pour croire à ce que la Bible nous parle
à propos de la création,
ne devrait pas pour nous dépendre
des confirmations scientifiques,
dans l'observation de la réalité.
Par contre, nous allons quand même dédier un moment,
pas aujourd'hui,
à considérer comment la science,
par ces vraies découvertes,
sont plutôt en train de confirmer
les récits bibliques littéraux de la création
que les contraires.
Mais le plus important pour nous,
dans la semaine dernière,
c'était de nous rappeler
qu'au-dessous de toute évidence logique,
philosophique, apologétique ou scientifique,
les clairs enseignements des Écritures
basés sur une interprétation biblique
doit être la base suprême d'autorité
à propos de la création pour nous, les chrétiens.
Même si vous n'avez pas,
même si vous n'avez pas,
vous ne devez pas devenir des experts
dans la connaissance des évidences scientifiques
pour croire avec toute assurance
que ce que la Bible enseigne à propos de la création
est vrai.
Elle ne peut pas vous donner tous les détails
que vous aimeriez savoir,
mais ce dont elle parle doit être pris comme vrai.
Et donc, la fonction surtout du pasteur,
avant de se sentir sous la pression
des découvertes d'autres champs des connaissances,
c'est de s'assurer
que son interprétation,
dans certains textes bibliques,
respecte les principes d'interprétation biblique
tels que la Bible elle-même nous dicte.
Et j'espère vous présenter
une presque totale inflexibilité d'interprétation
par rapport à Genèse,
qui est l'interprétation confessionnelle historique.
Et donc, ce qu'on a vu la semaine dernière,
c'est que l'interprétation littérale des Genès
est une question confessionnelle.
Nous sommes en train de lire la confession de foi,
et la confession de foi représente
ce qui l'Église a cru,
l'Église orthodoxe,
l'Église conservatrice,
l'Église véritable,
la bonne représentation de l'Église
au fil de l'histoire.
Elle a cru largement et majoritairement
à l'interprétation littérale des Genès.
Voilà pourquoi,
dans cette déclaration confessionnelle,
nous trouvons de manière très évidente,
au commencement,
il a plu à Dieu le Père,
les Fils, les Saint-Esprits,
pour la manifestation de sa gloire
et de son éternelle puissance,
de sa sagesse et de sa bonté,
de créer ou de faire en six jours
les mondes et tout ce qui se trouve,
choses visibles et invisibles,
et tout était très bon.
Vous êtes avec moi en six jours.
Et donc,
l'interprétation littérale des Genès
est une question confessionnelle.
Et donc, qu'est-ce qu'on a essayé de discuter,
de mieux rentrer ou mieux comprendre les débats,
on a considéré d'abord et avant tout
que l'univers ou l'origine de l'univers
n'est pas atteignable
par la méthode scientifique.
La méthode scientifique est apparue
beaucoup plus loin.
D'ailleurs,
la Genèse de la science positiviste
se passe avec des croyants,
des personnes qui croyaient
qu'ils pouvaient trouver des lois intelligentes
derrière l'univers,
car leur présupposition,
leur présupposé,
c'est que Dieu avait créé l'univers.
Si on chercherait aujourd'hui,
ou si on attendrait aujourd'hui
que la science serait faite
sur la base de la considération
d'un univers hasardieux,
ça serait très peu probable
que les personnes allaient s'aventurer
à trouver des lois dans un monde
dont l'énergie,
qui ne pense pas,
qui n'a pas de sentiments,
qui n'a pas d'intelligence,
aurait pu créer.
Donc la science même,
elle est née dans un contexte
qui présupposait
la réalité d'un Dieu intelligent
qui avait créé des lois
pour gouverner l'univers.
Mais la réalité,
c'est que l'origine de l'univers
n'est pas atteignable
par la méthode scientifique.
La méthode scientifique des bases,
c'est d'avoir des témoins
qui puissent observer un phénomène
et un phénomène qui se répète.
Et la réalité,
c'est que personne déjà n'a été présent
à part Dieu lui-même
à la création.
Et la réalité,
c'est que ce phénomène
n'est pas en train de se répéter.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que personne ne peut réclamer
faire un osage
d'une méthode scientifique
pour appeler une théorie
à propos de la création
comme si elle était loi,
comme si elle était certaine.
Nous pouvons nous demander
à comment les découvertes scientifiques
peuvent confirmer
plus ou moins,
peuvent jouer
pour la plus grande
ou la moins grande
probabilité
d'une théorie.
Mais nous ne pouvons jamais
présenter une théorie
avec une certitude,
une pleine certitude,
car ce n'est pas un phénomène
qui puisse se répéter
la création.
Et donc,
qu'est-ce que la science,
elle va faire
avec ses découvertes ?
Qu'est-ce que la philosophie
va faire avec ses découvertes ?
Elle va chercher
à imploser,
à invalider
une possible théorie
ou confirmer,
donner des preuves
qui vont soutenir
plus une théorie.
Il y a
trois groupes
de théories majeures
qui nous avons considérées
quand on pense
à l'origine de l'univers
et là,
même avant de discuter
la question religieuse,
car les créationnismes religieux
ou les créationnismes chrétiens,
il est une partie,
une branche,
si on peut dire comme ça,
de cette possibilité
logique
et intelligente
qu'un univers
intelligent
a une origine
intelligente.
Et donc,
les trois grands groupes
de théories
par rapport
à l'origine
de l'univers,
c'est
les premiers,
c'est qu'elle est
moins soutenable,
c'est la préexistence,
pardon,
c'est la génération
espontanée
de la matière.
Donc,
même si on va discuter
qu'il y a eu
des évolutions,
etc.,
la grande question
ultime,
c'est d'où sont venus
les premiers éléments
qui auraient pu
provoquer ou produire
ce qu'ils ont produit.
Et donc là,
il y a cette suggestion,
avant tout,
il n'y avait rien
et il y a eu
une génération
spontanée
de la matière.
Donc,
les rien n'ont pas
la capacité
de rien créer
et donc
l'argumentation
contraire
apologétique,
c'est de dire
tout simplement
qu'on n'a jamais
observé
les rien
apporter
quelque chose.
Et donc,
par une observation
logique et scientifique,
par un raisonnement logique
et une observation
scientifique,
les rien n'est jamais
en train de créer
quoi que ce soit.
La prochaine proposition,
c'est la préexistence
de la matière.
Pardon,
oui,
c'est ça,
comme si ces éléments
aient existé
pour toujours.
Et la troisième,
les troisèmes groupes
des théories,
c'est la théorie
de l'origine divine
ou intelligente.
Donc,
c'est de dire,
on va plander
des signes d'évidence
d'intelligence
dans l'univers.
Et donc,
on va se demander
comme une théorie
bien probable
que l'origine
de toutes les choses
est une origine intelligente.
Et à partir de là,
nous allons partir
pour faire de la science.
On va chercher
à corroborer
ou on va chercher
à imploser
une théorie
en examinant
les évidences
scientifiques
pour ou contre
ces théories.
Donc,
ce que nous devons
considérer,
c'est que
nous,
en tant que chrétiens,
on est du côté
des théories
de l'origine
intelligente
et particulièrement
en croyant
fermement
à la Bible
comme révélation.
Et donc,
nous,
nous devons savoir
dès le départ
qu'il est pour plus
qu'on s'approfondisse
pour étudier
la relation
entre
la théorie
d'un créationnisme
intelligent.
Et là,
la science,
de manière plus générale,
va pointer
dans cette direction
et nous pouvons étudier
les preuves scientifiques
dans cette direction.
Et plus particulièrement
pour nous,
on est plus intéressé
davantage
aux découvertes scientifiques
qui confirment
non seulement
une idée générale
d'une origine divine,
mais l'idée
précisément harmonisée
à celle
que la Bible
nous présente.
Et là,
ça va être un travail
pour les prochains
leçons.
Mais,
il faut se rappeler
que le plus important,
c'est de considérer
avant tout
les récits bibliques
comme suffisants,
car,
pour plus qu'on étudie
l'évidence de la science,
elle ne peut qu'être
fortifiée
une fois déjà existante
par la foi.
Nous croyons
que les choses
ont été créées
à partir des choses invisibles,
que l'univers a été créé
à partir des choses invisibles.
Et donc,
c'est important de rappeler,
elle peut fortifier
la foi existante,
mais de soi-même,
elles n'ont pas la capacité
d'engendrer la foi.
Certains d'entre nous
étant très étudiés
et très doués
et peut-être même
se sentant appelés
à s'approfondir
dans la connaissance
de l'évidence biblique,
nous pouvons être
utilisés par Dieu
même dans l'évangélisation,
mais comme disait
Schaeffer,
c'est plus efficace
d'emploser
un système
que la personne
a déjà créé
dans son incrédulité
contre Dieu
qui est d'engendrer
la foi,
car on dépend toujours
du Saint-Esprit
pour engendrer la foi.
Mais c'est important
car Dieu utilise aussi
cet entraînement
et ses ressources apologétiques
même pour l'évangélisation.
Et donc,
la relation entre la Bible
et la science
est quelque chose
d'important pour nous.
On a aussi
parlé un peu
sur ça.
Donc,
la première chose,
c'est de nous rappeler
qu'il y a plein
d'erreurs scientifiques
lorsque la science
réclame comme loi
ce qui sont
qui est des théories.
Et c'est ce qui s'est passé
avec l'évolutionnisme
de manière générale
car il y a plein
des versions
ou des branches
différentes
dans l'évolutionnisme
ou la théorie
de l'évolution.
Et la réalité,
c'est que parfois,
les théories
de l'évolution
nous sont communiquées
de manière
très populaire
comme en étant
des lois,
la vérité,
en démontrant
des preuves
qui, en vrai,
peuvent être
mises en question
à plusieurs égards
comme en étant
des preuves
indubitables
pour cette théorie.
Et donc,
ça c'est une erreur
lorsqu'il y a
science présente
des théories
comme si elles étaient
des lois.
Et de l'autre côté,
il y a eu pas mal
d'erreurs théologiques
dans l'histoire
où des mauvaises
interprétations bibliques
et des traditions
chrétiennes
se sont accrochées
à certaines interprétations
vis-à-vis
à la science
qui ne sont pas
forcément
la position biblique.
Mais la réalité,
c'est qu'il n'y a eu
jamais des contradictions
réelles
entre
une portion
de la Bible
correctement interprétée,
entre la Bible
tout simplement,
et les vraies
découvertes
de la science.
Il n'y a eu
jamais
des contradictions.
Et donc,
avant de céder
à la pression
du paradigme
scientifique
conventionnel,
l'évolutionnisme,
on aurait dû
mieux faire
déconnaître
déjà les faiblesses
scientifiques
de ces théories.
Il y en a plein,
il y a pas mal
de personnes
qui arrivent
à la fois
ou qui arrivent
à refuser
complètement
l'évolutionnisme
tout simplement
en contemplant
les trous
dans ces théories.
Et donc,
les personnes
qui connaissent
mieux la science
se portent
avec plus
de réticences
envers
cette théorie.
Mais surtout,
en considérant
nous,
l'Église,
on devrait
s'assurer
de l'enseignement
clair
et inflexible
de la Bible
par rapport
à la création.
Ça devrait
suffire pour nous
pour ne pas
tomber dans la tentation
de nous laisser porter
envers la théorie
de l'évolution
ou nous sentir
sous pression
pour changer
nos interprétations.
La catastrophe
théologique
des dernières
générations,
c'est car,
je vais vous lire,
afin de ne pas
paraître
ignorant
au sujet
des dernières
« découvertes »
scientifiques.
L'Église a non seulement
exposé son amateurisme
scientifique,
mais a également
adopté
un alphabétisme
biblique.
On a sacrifié
les méthodes
d'interprétation
bibliques
qu'on a élevées
comme les critères
les plus importants
pendant toutes les générations.
On a tordu
les textes bibliques.
Car le but
principal
de la révélation
spéciale
est
le salut.
La Bible
ne fait pas
du langage
scientifique
une priorité,
mais car
elle est divine.
Toute intercession
entre la Bible
et la science
sera vraie.
La Bible
aura toujours raison
et donc la Bible
est la source
suprême
et suffisante
d'autorité.
Si nous pouvons
arriver
à certaines considérations
à propos de la création
qui sont clairement
et inflexiblement
bibliques,
cela doit
suffire pour nous
et nous
nous pouvons être
davantage sûrs
que les vraies
découvertes
de la science
vont toujours
s'accorder à elle.
Car c'est impossible
que l'auteur
des deux livres
rentre en contradiction.
Les mêmes auteurs
de la Bible
sont l'auteur
de la nature
et donc il y aura
toujours
des cohérences
et d'harmonie
entre elles.
Et quelle est donc
la déclaration
historique
confessionnelle
pour nous ?
Quelle est
l'interprétation
biblique
des Genènes
qui a toujours
marqué
l'Église orthodoxe
selon l'histoire ?
C'est ce qu'on vient
de lire.
Au commencement,
il a plu à Dieu,
Père,
Fils et Saint-Esprit
pour la manifestation
de sa gloire
et de son éternelle
puissance,
de sa sagesse
et de sa bonté
de créer
ou de faire
en six jours
les mondes
et tout ce qui se trouve.
Chose invisible
et visible
et tout était très bon.
La première chose
qu'on a fait,
c'est déporter
cette définition
doctrinale.
Voici la manière
résumée
de traiter,
de confesser,
de croire
à cette doctrine.
C'est de reconnaître
tous les composants
de ses premiers paragraphes.
Ici,
c'est le fondement
confessionnel
à propos de la création
de l'univers.
Pour porter
une définition
qui va qualifier
plutôt l'acte
des créations,
les théologies thématiques
comme la citation
de Louis Bercoff
nous présente,
il va dire le suivant.
La création
est un acte
souverain des dieux
par lesquels
il produit à partir
des riens
tout ce qui existe.
Et c'est là
dans un but ultime,
la manifestation
de sa propre gloire.
Cet acte créateur
est libre,
immédiat
et absolument dépendant
de la volonté divine.
Dieu a créé
un monde
séparé de lui-même
et toutefois
complètement dépendant
de lui-même.
Il n'est pas
comme un horloger
qui a donné corps
dans un horloge
et abandonné
comme propose
la science positiviste
moderne.
C'est-à-dire,
ils veulent croire
que l'univers
est un système
fermé
où nous ne pouvons
que découvrir
des lois
qui expliquent
leur fonctionnement
interne
sans croire
qu'il y a une intervention
et même un maintien
surnaturel
qui est là
en train d'intervenir
dans ce monde.
Et ça,
c'est l'un des présupposés
principaux
pour lesquels
ils veulent
s'enfuir
des évidences
et même des évidences
scientifiques.
Et donc,
les textes principaux
que nous trouvons
de manière très résumée
cette vérité,
c'est Genèse chapitre 1
et je pense
que les versets 1 à 5
devraient nous suffire
pour considérer
l'intentionnalité
de l'auteur
qui a dû décrire
les commencements,
donc au commencement.
Et donc déjà,
on devrait nous laisser porter
car c'est très intéressant.
Ces passages
visent à définir
véritablement
les commencements
de la terre.
Et ça,
c'est une introduction
à l'ensemble
dans la structure textuelle,
c'est à l'ensemble
du récit.
Et donc là,
on est devant
les commencements
ou les débuts
de l'histoire
où les termes
ou l'expression
dans l'hébraïque
veut dire tout simplement
histoire.
Donc l'interprétation
ne peut,
ne pas être
non historique
car déjà,
on a ces indices
d'historicité.
Mais c'est intéressant,
il y en a ceux
qui veulent accorder
à Genèse
et adapter
et on va voir
d'autres trous
qu'ils cherchent
à trouver
dans les passages
en faisant la séparation
par exemple
entre les versets 1
et les versets 2.
Mais pour l'instant,
je voulais juste
qu'on se laisse porter
par la lecture naturelle
de texte
en suggérant
que la création
des végétations,
des animaux
et particulièrement
des lettres morts
ont fait partie
du commencement.
Ils n'ont pas fait partie
car si on suit
la logique évolutionniste,
on est plutôt
vers la fin de l'histoire,
si la terre
a déjà
des milliards
et des milliards
de données.
Ici,
c'est la description
du commencement
et l'êtrement
a participé
très naturellement
du commencement.
Hébreu 11,
3 nous dit
que c'est par la foi
que nous reconnaissons
que le monde
a été formé
par la parole
de Dieu
en sorte
que ce qu'on voit
n'a pas été fait
des choses visibles.
Et donc,
nous avons déjà
considéré
quelques affirmations
principales
qui composent
ces paragraphes
confessionnels.
la première,
ce sont les questions
qu'on pose,
c'est qui,
avec quel but,
quand et comment.
OK ?
Et donc,
on a déjà traité
les qui
et les avec
quel but.
Et les qui,
c'est intéressant,
au commencement,
il a plu à Dieu,
père,
fils et saint-esprit.
donc,
les trois personnes
de la Trinité
sont engagées
dans la création.
C'est un travail
qui a pour but
manifester la gloire
des dieux.
Et donc,
c'est clair
que l'engagement
des trois personnes
de la Trinité
dans la création
de toutes les choses
pour manifester
les emprunts
d'un dieu sage,
infiniment puissant,
une des questions
qu'on peut poser
et qu'on doit se poser,
c'est,
est-ce que
des dépendres
citants
d'une terre
si vieille
a plus ou moins
la capacité
de maximiser
la gloire d'un dieu
qui aurait pu créer
toutes les choses
d'un seul coup.
Et donc,
voilà pourquoi,
avec quel but est important
aussi comme réponse.
On a vu plusieurs textes
qui nous montrent
l'engagement du père,
du fils et du saint-esprit
dans la création.
La deuxième question,
c'était avec quel but.
Donc,
Dieu a créé toutes choses
exactement de la manière
dont il a créé
toutes les choses,
c'est-à-dire
les récits bibliques
cherchent à nous démontrer
que Dieu a créé
les choses
exactement de cette manière
afin de maximiser
la gloire
de son nom.
Et donc,
afin de maximiser
la révélation
de sa gloire
pour son plaisir.
Donc,
il n'y a aucune raison
extérieure à Dieu,
il n'y a aucune nécessité
en Dieu
de créer toutes les choses.
Il a créé
toutes ces choses
afin de maximiser
sa gloire,
afin de révéler
afin de prendre plaisir
dans une création
qui sort
de lui-même.
Donc,
nous avons vu
comment nous sommes
les bénéficiaires aussi,
car lorsque Dieu
va glorifier son nom
et qu'il va créer
des êtres à son image,
les êtres les plus,
dans la position
la plus avantageuse,
ce sont ceux
qui peuvent
décodifier la gloire
de Dieu
dans la création
et louer Dieu
et être en relation
avec Dieu.
Et donc là,
on n'a pas,
la Bible ne nous présente
pas quelque part
les pourquoi,
mais elle nous présente
le avec le but.
Et le but,
c'était de manifester
la gloire de Dieu.
On a vu aussi
plein de passages bibliques
et aussi dans les contextes
de Genèse,
tout était bon,
tout était bon.
Après l'homme,
tout était très bon
et Dieu,
au septième jour,
va contempler sa création,
va prendre plaisir
dans sa création.
Donc d'abord et avant tout,
pour son plaisir,
il n'a plus de Dieu,
mais aussi pour les biens
de toutes ses créatures.
Donc on a considéré aussi
cette question,
les qui.
Et ensuite,
on passe à la considération
du comment.
Et donc,
quand on considère
comment Dieu
a créé toutes les choses
afin de maximiser sa gloire,
nous prenons en considération
l'ordre en soi
qui est très structuré
dans les passages bibliques.
Mais il y a cette question
donc qui va se diviser
entre les quand
et les comment.
Les quand et de quelle manière.
Tout cela, c'est comment.
Et nous allons commencer
aujourd'hui par les quand.
et vis-à-vis
à toutes ces interactions
avec les nouvelles théories
et nouvelles interprétations
bibliques,
c'est particulièrement
la question cruciale.
Notamment car
pour chercher
par manque d'évidence
scientifique,
par manque
des vraies découvertes
scientifiques
qui puissent
supporter
la théorie de l'évolution,
l'une des solutions
auxquelles
elle fait recours,
c'est de suggérer
des âges
et des âges
qui puissent justifier
la complexité
et l'intelligence
des choses
telles qu'elles sont aujourd'hui.
Car ils sont en train
de jouer
avec la probabilité
hasardeuse.
Et donc la réalité,
c'est que pour nous,
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
non seulement
que la manière
dont la Bible
a été enregistrée
nous présente
la question
du temps
comme une question
centrale
en Génèles chapitre 1,
car on veut
structurer ces choses
de manière
à maximiser
la gloire de Dieu
exactement
par la manière
dont Dieu
a tout fait.
Et donc mon objectif
aujourd'hui,
c'est de considérer
surtout
combien inflexible
on devrait considérer
l'interprétation
littérale
des Génès.
Et donc,
au commencement,
paragraphe pour nous,
il n'a plus Dieu,
Père,
Fils et Saint-Esprit
pour la manifestation
de sa gloire
et de son éternelle
puissance.
Donc,
qu'est-ce que Dieu
vise à manifester ?
Sa gloire
éternelle puissance.
Donc,
qu'est-ce qui peut
plus maximiser
la puissance de Dieu,
la gloire
de la puissance
de Dieu,
de sa sagesse
et de sa bonté
de créer
ou de faire
en six jours
les mondes
et tous
ce qui se trouvent,
choses visibles
et invisibles
et tout était très bon.
selon la compréhension
et l'interprétation
traditionnelle,
conservatrice,
historique,
la manière
qui maximise
le plus
la bonté,
la sagesse,
la puissance
des dieux,
c'est d'avoir créé
le monde
en six jours.
Et donc,
nous savons
qu'il y a aujourd'hui
au moins quatre propositions
principales
d'interprétation
de Genèse
et plutôt
par rapport
à ces
qui touchent
l'âge
de la terre
et donc,
il y a
ce qu'on appelle
l'interprétation
littérale
ou historique,
c'est celle
qu'on va défendre.
Il y a
l'interprétation
du jour
comme une période
plus longue,
les jours
symboliques,
donc on va chercher
d'autres passages
bibliques
pour dire
pour Dieu,
un jour c'est comme
mille ans,
etc.
et on essaye
de suggérer par là
un symbolisme.
On va voir
combien contraire
c'est,
même à la compréhension
même de cette parabole,
elle perdrait
l'essence
ou la signification
si on ne les prend pas
à la considération
du jour
comme on les connaît
de manière littérale.
Elle ne peut pas
servir comme métaphore
si on ne prend pas
les sens littéral
du jour
quand on est en train
de lire
cette explication.
Mais plus que ça,
on va avoir
plein d'évidence
d'historicité littérale
de ce qu'on va y trouver
en Genèse
lui-même.
Et donc,
il y a
cette deuxième
interprétation.
La troisième
interprétation,
c'est
l'interprétation
voilà,
une interprétation
allégorique
ou symbolique
où on est plus
en train
de considérer
l'essence
théologique
et une espèce
d'ordre,
c'est comme si Dieu
faisait usage
de cette histoire,
possiblement mythologique,
juste pour nous donner
des indices
théologiques
ou des vérités
plutôt spirituelles.
Ça, c'est sous
surtout l'influence
du néoplatonisme.
On n'aura pas
le temps, je pense,
de nous approfondir,
mais certains font
usage d'Augustin
pour suggérer
une possible
interprétation
qui puisse justifier
la Terre vieille.
Et pour plus
qu'Augustin,
sous l'influence
néoplatoniste,
il était porté
à présenter
plus
une position
qui donnait
plus l'essence
spirituelle
et théologique
des vérités
qui est l'essence
littérale,
n'était pas très fermée
au sens littéral
des 24 heures,
mais il n'était pas
du tout sous l'influence
de la possibilité
d'une Terre vieille
et l'ensemble
de sa théologie
se porte plus
dans sa direction
des Terres jaunes,
d'historicité
jaune de la Terre.
Et il y a aussi
l'interprétation
du framework
ou les cadres
fonctionnels
où on voit
plutôt
une structure
qui cherche
à représenter
l'ordre
et les fonctions
de la création
l'accent
est plus mis
sur la souveraineté
des dieux
et l'organisation
de l'univers
plus que sur
la chronologie
exacte
de la création.
Et il y a aussi
cette alternative
du guêpe
qui va entrer
un peu
dans la considération
de la séparation
entre les versets
1 et 2.
au commencement,
Dieu créa
laissé la Terre
et ensuite
la Terre
était
informe
et vide.
C'est comme si
un événement
cataclysmatique
a eu lieu
et qui a porté
une première chute
avant la création
de l'homme.
Pour certains,
c'est la chute
de Satan.
Et ensuite,
ça va décrire
et ça expliquerait
pour eux
une Terre vieille,
etc.
Et nous allons voir
comment aucun
de ces arguments,
aucune de ces théories
ne peuvent
être soutenues
devant
l'évidence biblique.
Et là,
je vais plutôt
vous proposer
rien que par
les traitements,
c'est ma fonction,
c'est mon domaine
en tant que théologien,
en tant que pasteur,
rien que par
des principes
d'interprétation biblique,
l'interprétation littérale
est inflexible
de Genèse.
Donc,
nous allons considérer
de manière
plus positive.
Donc,
je vais vous présenter
quelques arguments,
je ne vais pas vous dire
les nombres,
mais on va aller
au fur et à mesure
pour démontrer
pourquoi nous devons
interpréter Genèse
chapitre 1
comme littéral.
La première,
c'est la cohérence
directe,
la signification
des mots
et la suture.
OK ?
Donc,
quand on va observer
la suture en Genèse,
on va voir comment
les textes
ont d'abord été
suturés
avec le but
de présenter
l'histoire.
Donc,
selon les ébranches,
la majorité
des ébranches
les plus érudites,
nous allons reconnaître
que Genèse
doit être compris
comme histoire,
OK ?
Au commencement,
histoire.
Et ensuite,
c'est intéressant
de voir
qu'à chaque fois
on voit cette suture
qui se répète,
ainsi,
il a eu un soir
et un matin.
Et donc,
les premiers jours,
c'est important,
ainsi,
il y a eu,
il y a eu
un soir
et un matin.
Et quand on se pose
la question
comment on aurait pu
mesurer,
car c'est ça,
ça c'est l'une des propositions
qui veulent suggérer
que peut-être
que pour les trois
premiers jours,
on avait
des airs,
des périodes
très longues,
des milliards d'années.
Mais c'est clair
qu'après la création
du soleil,
qui a été créée
pour marquer les jours
et la lune
pour marquer la nuit,
à partir de là,
on peut s'accorder
les trois derniers jours,
c'était littéral
24 heures.
Donc déjà,
on n'a pas ce choix
car les termes en soi
ne changent pas
selon les contextes,
c'est les mêmes termes
pour définir jour,
c'est la même qualification
de terme,
c'est-à-dire,
il y a eu
un soir et un matin
et le mouvement,
il est très clair.
C'est de voir la fin
qui a été plus immédiatement
décrite,
c'est-à-dire,
Dieu a tout fait
les premiers jours,
verset 5,
Dieu appela la lumière
jour et appela
les ténèbres nuit.
Ainsi,
il y a eu un soir
et un matin,
c'est-à-dire,
comme la dernière chose
qu'il a décrite,
c'était la nuit,
il va dire,
il y a eu un soir
qu'on est en train
de regarder
et regardant
en arrière
vers les débuts
des jeunesses,
il y a eu un matin.
Donc c'est intéressant,
au commencement,
Dieu créa les cieux
et la terre,
la terre était en forme vide.
Donc quand on se demande,
est-ce qu'on peut avoir
des séparations
entre les versets 1 et 2 ?
Quand est-ce que
cette première section
finit selon la structure
du chapitre ?
Elle finit à partir
du moment où on va décrire
en regardant en arrière,
ainsi,
en soir et en matin.
Et donc comment
jussifle les marquages
du temps ?
C'est clair et évident
dans les textes.
Dieu appela
la lumière jour,
ça peut nous échapper.
Comment
la lumière
que Dieu a créée,
cette matière primaire
à partir de laquelle
il va utiliser aussi
pour faire les soleils
plus tard,
mais elle était déjà
suffisamment fonctionnelle
et utile
pour qu'elle sert
pour Dieu
à marquer
jour et nuit.
Il appelait
les ténèbres nuit
et la lumière
jour.
Donc c'est déjà
la manière
dont Dieu a voulu
structurer.
Et la structure,
ce fut les premiers jours.
Qu'est-ce qui est compris
dans les premiers jours ?
Tout ce qu'on lit
d'ici en arrière.
Au commencement,
jusqu'à ce fut
les premiers jours,
c'est la première section.
On va voir plus tard
comment
Exode chapitre 20
va nous montrer
la même chose.
Au commencement,
Dieu créa
les cieux et la terre.
Exode chapitre 20
va nous dire
au commencement,
Dieu créa
les cieux et la terre
en six jours.
Donc pour qu'il n'y ait
aucune possibilité
que toute la création
ait été décrite
dans les six jours.
Et on va voir ça plus tard.
Pour l'instant,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer tout simplement
la structure
et la signification
du mot.
Ça ne change pas.
C'est jour, nuit,
soir, matin
et c'est ça qui marque
les jours
des 24 heures.
Ensuite,
il y a la cohérence.
Voilà.
La cohérence
structurelle
et la cohérence
de chaque jour,
soir et matin,
qui va marquer
toujours
chaque jour
de la création
jusqu'au sixième.
Donc sans la possibilité
de traiter certains
comme R
et d'autres comme littéral.
La troisième,
c'est la cohérence
contextuelle plus large.
Donc là,
c'est cette relation
ou ces rapports
entre les trois derniers jours
et les trois premiers jours
qui ont la même structure.
On ne peut pas traiter
les trois premiers jours
différents
des trois derniers jours.
et la cohérence fonctionnelle
qui est à la une
logique
et biologique.
Donc,
si nous sommes devant
des jours symboliques,
tout ce que Dieu a créé
serait disparu
si la création
biologique
qui a besoin
de cet équilibre parfait
entre lumière,
entre ténèbres,
si toute la création
était exposée
à des airs,
des ténèbres,
tout serait mort.
On n'a pas comment
maintenir la création
par des airs,
que ce soit
les trois premiers jours
seuls
ou tous les autres jours.
Car la Bible est claire
pour dire
que ces périodes
étaient marquées
par ténèbres
et lumière.
C'est important
de remarquer aussi
la question
des interdépendances
fonctionnelles
dans la création.
Donc,
quand on considère
par exemple
Genèse chapitre 1,
verset 9,
Dieu dit
que les eaux
qui sont au-dessus
du ciel
se rassemblent
en un seul lieu
et que les secs
apparaissent.
Et cela fut ainsi.
Dieu appela
les secs terres,
il appela
la masse
des eaux
mères,
Dieu vit
que cela a été bon.
Puis Dieu dit
que la terre
produise
de la verdure,
de l'herbre
portant de la sémence,
des arbres
fruitifères
donnant du fruit
selon leur espèce
et ayant en eux
leur sémence
sur la terre.
et ce fut ainsi.
La terre produisit
de la verdure,
de l'herbre
portant de la sémence
selon son espèce,
des arbres
donnant du fruit
et ayant en eux
leur sémence
selon leur espèce.
Dieu vit que cela a été bon.
ainsi,
en soir,
et en matin,
ce fut le troisième jour.
Donc,
observez bien,
déjà,
selon leur espèce.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Chaque herbe
et chaque arbre
avec du fruit
en ayant déjà la sémence,
c'est-à-dire
les codes ADN
qui allaient faire
que chaque espèce
se reproduirait
pour se développer
à nouveau
parfaitement
en arbre,
seraient là.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
la terre a été créée
et les éléments
de la création
ont été créés
avec apparence
d'âge,
malgré le fait
que Dieu venait
de les créer.
Il a créé
des arbres
donnant du fruit
ayant en eux
leur sémence.
Donc,
on arrive
et on contemple
l'arbre
basé sur
l'observation scientifique
de nos jours,
on dirait
que cet arbre
aurait 30 ans.
Mais si
nous sommes ici
dans la position
d'Adam
lorsqu'il a été créé
et qu'il contemple
cet arbre,
même si l'arbre
avait l'apparence
des 30 ans,
cet arbre avait
un jour.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est qu'Adam lui-même
a été créé
homme fait,
on dirait,
30 ans peut-être,
avec apparence d'âge.
Qu'est-ce que la science
observe aujourd'hui ?
Elle essaye
de faire des datations
par l'observation
des choses
qui,
par des phénomènes
naturels,
se reproduisent
ou sont là,
tout simplement.
On essaie
de calculer.
On ne prend pas
en considération
la possibilité
de Dieu
avoir créé
la terre
déjà avec
une apparence
d'âge.
Et donc,
il y a non seulement
la question logique
qui est là,
il y a aussi
la question
de cette interdépendance.
C'est intéressant,
Genèse 2,
verset 5,
c'est une description
plus détaillée.
Si Genèse 1,
c'est une description
plus résumée,
Genèse 2,
c'est une description
plus détaillée
en ayant l'homme
au centre de l'histoire.
Donc,
lorsque l'éternel Dieu
fit une terre
et des cieux,
aucun arbuste
des champs
n'était encore
sur la terre
et aucune herbe
des champs
n'est germé encore
car l'éternel Dieu
n'avait pas fait
plus voir
sur la terre
et il n'y avait
point d'homme
pour cultiver
les sols.
Et donc,
pourquoi
c'est nécessaire
que tous ces systèmes
très complexes
qui Dieu a créés
soient créés
dans une période
si courte
à cause
de l'interdépendance
de ces éléments
pour continuer
de faire
cet univers
se développer.
Tous les animaux
dont on a besoin
pour même
cultiver la terre
aussi,
pour contribuer
à faire la distribution
des sémences.
Tout l'équilibre,
là,
on parle de l'interaction
entre l'homme
qui devrait être là
pour cultiver les sols,
pour donner suite
à la création,
mais nous devrions aussi
prendre en considération
comme on espère
les faire
dans les autres leçons,
de voir
toutes les évidences
cosmologiques
et toutes les évidences
microbiologiques
pour comprendre
comment cette interaction
est nécessaire.
Pourquoi ?
Dans la dépendance
qui est l'être
le moins complexe
qu'on puisse imaginer,
l'être qui a la vie,
il n'a pas la capacité
de tolérer
un temps d'évolution
très large
car il y a plusieurs choses
qui existent
dans son système
pour les faire marcher
qui sont interdépendantes
et qui sont très complexes
et qui doivent être créées
au même temps
dans une période
si courte
comme était la Terre.
Et donc,
on voit l'interdépendance
entre les éléments
de la Terre
qui joue pour la nécessité
d'une création
qui soit dans une courte période.
Donc,
il y a aussi
non seulement
cette cohérence
logique
ou biologique
évidente
déjà en Genèse,
mais il y a aussi
la cohérence théologique
et là,
les mouvements
vers l'apogée
de la description
de la création
et voilà pourquoi
Genèse
n'a pas
une proposition
scientifique.
Le but de Genèse,
lorsqu'elle touchera
la science,
elle aura raison,
elle sera correcte,
il y aura toujours
de la vraie harmonie
mais la réalité,
c'est que
l'intérêt biblique
c'est de nous donner
une description
de la création
de manière à maximiser
la gloire des dieux
et au centre
de l'histoire,
l'être humain
qui a été créé,
l'apogée
de la création
à l'image des dieux.
Et donc,
les mouvements
vers l'apothéose
s'est chronologiquement
complètement connecté
car la terre
est les scénarios
d'appréciation
de la gloire des dieux
particulièrement
pour l'être humain.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
Dieu dit
que la terre
produise des animaux
vivants
selon leur espèce
et donc là,
c'est le sixième jour,
ok,
mais c'est 24,
du bétail,
des reptiles,
des animaux terrestres
selon leur espèce.
Donc,
voyez,
l'emphase divine
pour qu'on ne puisse
pas être flexible
envers l'évolution
entre les espèces,
ok,
chaque animal
a été créé
selon leur espèce,
chaque arbre
a été créé
selon leur espèce.
Et cela fut ainsi,
Dieu fit les animaux
de la terre
selon leur espèce,
les bétails
selon leur espèce
et tous les reptiles
de la terre
selon leur espèce.
Dieu vit
que cela a été bon.
Puis Dieu dit,
et là,
c'est vraiment
une pause
très importante
car à chaque fois,
Dieu est en train
de créer
toutes les choses
de manière glorieuse
mais sans aucune pause
et ici,
nous voyons
cette introduction
d'un langage pluriel
qui semble suggérer
une espèce
de réunion trinitaire.
Faisons l'homme
à notre image
selon notre rassemblance.
Donc,
pas selon
tout simplement
leur espèce.
Nous sommes une seule espèce,
la race humaine,
ok,
mais notre espèce
n'est pas selon
l'espèce généraliste
de tous les êtres créés.
Nous sommes créés
à l'image
ou selon l'espèce
quelque part
des dieux,
à l'image
et à la rassemblance
des dieux.
Et là,
c'est intéressant,
et qu'ils dominent
sur les poissons de la mer,
sur les oiseaux du ciel,
sur les bétails,
toute la terre.
Dieu créa l'homme
à son image,
il les créa
à l'image des dieux,
hommes et femmes.
Dieu les bénit,
leur dit,
soyez féconds,
multipliez,
remplissez la terre
et la sujétissez.
Donc c'est très important.
Et dominez sur les poissons
de la mer,
sur les oiseaux du ciel
et sur tout animal
qui s'émeut sur la terre.
Donc si l'être humain
est le sommet de la création,
est l'image des dieux,
est les moyens
par lesquels
dans la création,
Dieu va maximiser
davantage
la révélation de sa gloire
dans la création,
comment on aurait pu
attendre déjà
qu'il y ait des milliers
et des milliers
d'années
et entre les débuts
de la création
qui a pour but
de révéler la gloire
de Dieu
dans l'homme.
Et plus que ça,
c'est l'homme lui-même
qui va donner du sens
à la création.
C'est l'homme lui-même
qui va exercer
une interaction
envers cette création
afin d'agir
en tant qu'image
de Dieu
au sein de la création.
Donc il n'y a aucune
logique théologique
en cherchant
à suggérer
que les mouvements
de la création
de l'homme,
de la terre,
aient pris
si longtemps
pour que la race
humaine soit développée
ou que des âges
soient là.
Si l'objectif
de Dieu
c'est que l'univers
soit les scénarios
dans lesquels
ou les théâtres
cosmiques
dans lesquels
la gloire de Dieu
est révélée,
à qui de contempler
cette gloire
si c'est précisément
pour que l'homme
contemple
si nous avons
des milliers
et des milliers
d'années
qui sont là.
Et donc ici
c'est intéressant,
la cohérence théologique
est très importante,
elle va traverser
toutes les écritures
et c'est vrai
qu'il y a
un mouvement
de contemplation
qui peut être
un peu trompeur
quand on contemple
l'univers.
Donc même David
nous a aidé
à corriger
cette mauvaise intuition.
Quand je contemple
les cieux,
psaume 8,
ouvrage de tes mains,
la lune
et les étoiles
que tu as créées,
qu'est-ce qu'est l'homme
pour que tu te souviens
de lui ?
Donc on a l'impression
que lorsque Dieu
nous a créés
de cette manière,
qu'on étudie
les cosmos,
on a l'impression
que Dieu a tout créé
de cette manière
pour révéler
notre petitesse.
Et dans un certain sens,
ça peut révéler
notre petitesse
à plusieurs égards.
Mais c'est précisément
les contraires
que Dieu a voulu
démontrer à la race humaine.
Pourquoi ?
Je ne veux pas m'opposer
catégoriquement
à la possibilité
de trouver de la vie
dans d'autres planètes.
Mais les évidents scientifiques
sont très décourageantes
à cet égard,
progressivement décourageantes.
Et plus que ça,
l'enseignement biblique
se porte plutôt
dans la direction
de démontrer
que tout cela
a été créé
pour orner
la relation
de l'image des dieux
avec ces dieux glorieux
qui a tout préparé
pour couronner
la création
et donner douce sens
à la création
par la capacité
de l'être humain
de contempler
dans les micro-univers
et dans les macro-univers
la sagesse,
la bonté
et la gloire des dieux.
Et donc,
tout est en train d'orner.
Voilà pourquoi
David,
il continue dans son psaume.
C'est intéressant.
Qui est l'homme
pour qui tu te souviens
de lui
et les fils de l'homme
pour qui tu prennes garde à lui ?
Tu l'as fait
des peu inférieurs à Dieu
et tu l'as couronné
de gloire et magnificence.
Tu lui as donné
la domination
sur les œuvres de ta mort.
Tu as mis
sous ses pieds
les brébis
comme les bœufs,
les animaux des champs,
les oiseaux du ciel,
les poissons de la mer,
tous ceux qui parcourent
les sentiers de la mer,
éternel notre Dieu
qui est ton nom magnifique
sur toute la terre.
Et donc,
tout l'entourage
n'a pas été fait
pour montrer
tout simplement
la petitesse de l'homme
mais pour monter
l'importance
de l'image
de Dieu
dans cet univers.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
c'est les mêmes mouvements
de Genèse,
c'est la manière
dont Dieu est en train
de préparer
tous les terres.
La Bible nous présente
Dieu comme celui
qui a créé
toutes les étoiles,
il connaît leur nombre,
il les appelle
par leur nom.
Et donc,
ça c'est très important
de nous rappeler
comment c'est un acte
défini.
Et donc,
c'est l'opposé
de l'évolution
qu'on voit,
surtout dans ces mouvements.
bon,
quand on regarde
les rapports
entre l'homme
et les restes
de la création,
même lorsqu'on arrive
en roman chapitre 8,
la description
du fait
que c'est l'homme
qui donne du sens
à la création,
car à cause
de la chute humaine,
la création
a été rendue
vaine,
soumise
à la vanité
en tant qu'otage
de la corruption
de l'homme.
Donc,
tellement
l'univers
est à service
de l'homme,
tellement l'homme
est au centre
quelque part
de l'univers
en tant qu'image
de Dieu,
sur Dieu
et le centre
de tout,
pour être clair,
mais c'est important
vis-à-vis
à la création,
tellement central
à la création
que nous ne pourrions
pas attendre
faire la séparation,
la division
comme si l'homme
était un accident
d'évolution
ou temporellement,
l'implication temporelle,
il n'y a aucun sens
pour que Dieu
réporte
la centralité
de la création,
la courante
même car
Dieu va reposer
après avoir créé
l'homme.
Et donc,
hommes et femmes
créés à l'image
des dieux
sont au sommet
de la création
et même dans
les ministères
du Christ,
nous voyons
cette emphase
qui est remise
lorsqu'il Christ
va faire tout
converger en lui,
les médiateurs
entre Dieu
et homme.
Donc,
1 Corinthiens 11,
7,
l'homme ne doit pas
se couvrir la tête
puisqu'il a l'image
de la gloire de Dieu,
tandis que la femme
est la gloire de l'homme.
En effet,
l'homme n'a pas été
tiré de la femme,
mais la femme
a été tirée de l'homme.
L'homme n'a pas été
créé à cause de la femme,
mais la femme
a été créée
à cause de l'homme.
Donc,
c'est un abordage
historique de Genèse,
mais le point pour nous
pour l'instant,
c'est de nous rappeler
l'importance
de voir l'homme
comme une partie centrale
de la création
au commencement
et de ne pas être tenté
à séparer chronologiquement
la création
et l'homme
qui était le centre
de cette création.
Le même langage
va se répéter,
la même idée
avec l'emphase
des romans 5,
les premiers
et les deuxièmes Adam,
donc en faisant
la liaison entre Christ
et Adam,
et les reflets,
et Jésus
qui nous a présenté
comme les reflets
de la gloire de Dieu
et l'empreinte de sa personne.
À nouveau,
si la création
a pour but
révéler la gloire de Dieu
et si la gloire de Dieu
est particulièrement révélée
dans l'homme
en tant qu'image de Dieu,
les Christ
étant l'empreinte
de sa gloire,
l'empreinte
de sa personne,
c'est-à-dire
les Christ
étant par excellence
cette gloire
manifestée,
cette image
glorieuse,
les Christ,
les fils de Dieu
incarné,
c'est important
de nous rappeler
que l'intentionnalité
centrale de Dieu
dans cette création
qui a été faite
dans ces six jours
était surtout
de porter
le plus tôt possible
l'homme
au scénario.
Et donc là,
c'est intéressant,
étant les reflets
de sa gloire,
l'empreinte de sa personne
et soutenant
toutes les choses
par sa parole puissante
à faire la purification
des péchés
et s'est assis
à droite
de la majesté divine
dans les lieux très hauts.
Et donc,
il y a
cette centralité
historique
du Christ
en tant que médiateur
entre Dieu et homme
qui donne davantage
de sens
à l'opposé
de l'idée de l'évolution.
Donc,
on a qu'aider
l'involution
à partir de la création
d'Adam et Ève
et de la rédemption
qui est centrée
sur Christ,
les médiateurs
parfaits et du homme.
voilà pourquoi,
pour les mettre
en exécution
lorsque l'étant
serait accompli.
Et donc,
imaginez-vous,
si la terre
est si vieille
que ça,
on peut considérer
l'histoire
comme en ayant
l'enregistrement,
on va dire,
de l'histoire humaine,
quelque chose
de très récent
par rapport
aux milliards
et aux milliards
d'années.
Mais ici,
la Bible,
elle a catégorie
pour dire
que lorsque l'étant
serait accompli
,
déréunir toutes choses
en Christ,
celles qui sont
dans les cieux
et celles qui sont
sur la terre.
C'est qu'il nous conduit
à une lecture
de l'histoire
qui a l'homme
comme centre,
qui a Christ au centre.
Donc,
lorsqu'il Christ est venu,
2000 ans,
nous sommes quelque part
au sommet de l'histoire,
à la plénitude
de l'histoire.
Et c'est une histoire
qui est liée
à l'histoire
de l'humanité.
Donc,
les mouvements bibliques,
j'aurais pu vous citer
d'autres passages
comme Ephésiens chapitre
1,
Colossiens chapitre 1.
Mais les mouvements bibliques,
c'est de nous montrer
comment,
chronologiquement,
dans la création,
l'image des dieux
est la couronne
et l'essence
de la création.
Sixième argument,
la cohérence interne
des Écritures.
D'abord et avant tout,
les évidences historiques
des Genès.
Je vous ai déjà présenté
que les termes
Genès signifient
histoire lui-même.
Mais c'est intéressant,
il y a des évidences
de la littérature historique
dans la Genèse elle-même.
Donc,
par exemple,
déjà,
quand on compare
la littérature mythologique
de l'époque
avec les textes bibliques
de la Pentateuch,
nous allons voir
qu'en général,
une présentation mythologique
de la Genèse,
à chaque fois,
sera très poétique.
Elle sera
possiblement
faite par des chansons.
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment
les indices
littéraux
internes
sont plus vers
une structure
littérale
et historique.
Voilà pourquoi
les marquages
du temps
sont quelque chose
de remarquable
quand on compare
la littérature.
Par exemple,
des biens
rythmés
avec la définition
si littérale,
si préoccupée,
soir et matin,
premier jour,
deuxième jour,
c'est l'opposé
de vouloir suggérer
une interprétation
poétique.
C'est vraiment
pour marquer
chronologiquement
les récits de Genèse.
Et donc,
l'évidence textuelle
va avoir
une harmonie parfaite.
Personne ne peut
dicter de manière
arbitraire
quelle portion
de Genèse
est poétique,
quelle portion
de Genèse
est littérale.
Ça, c'est très important
car si nous nous portons
vers ce type
de décision arbitraire,
toute la Bible
sera susceptible
à des interprétations
poétiques
ou métaphoriques.
Et donc,
la question,
c'est,
OK,
on a la littérature
des sagesses
dans la Bible,
les psaumes,
OK,
l'ecclésiaste
qui est une littérature
un peu plus poétique.
C'est clair,
c'est évident pour tous.
C'est auto-évident.
Par contre,
quand on s'approche
des Genès,
la majorité
écrasante
d'indices
historiques
sont partout
en Genèse.
Et notamment
même dans les premiers versets,
notamment même
dans les premiers chapitres.
Et là,
c'est important
de les prendre
avec la même cohérence.
Donc,
l'évidence textuelle
de Genèse,
on voit déjà
les précisions géographiques
et les précisions généalogiques.
Quel est l'intérêt
de vouloir
nous conduire
à identifier
aidant
avec la précision
par ces rivières
qui sont en train
décroisées
et qui sont identifiables
historiquement.
La précision
par rapport
aux généalogies.
Les précisions
par rapport
à la dimension
de l'arche
de l'Alliance,
par exemple,
de l'arche
de Noé,
par exemple,
et la durée
des jours
de déluge.
Et la quantité
de fois
où ces déluge
nous est présenté
comme
un événement
global,
universel.
La relation
entre les fils
de Noé
et les peuples
formés
autour d'Israël
au Moyen-Orient.
Quand on lit
la Bible,
on est très critérieux
pour chercher
à identifier
d'où sont venues
ces nations
qui s'opposent
à Israël
dans l'histoire
d'Israël,
desquelles Dieu
va les délivrer
à plusieurs reprises.
Toutes ces guerres,
c'est très important,
historiquement parlant,
et sont confirmées
historiquement
par des enregistrements
historiques parallèles
à la Bible.
Et là,
c'est très intéressant,
ces généalogies
qui portent
depuis Adam
jusqu'à Noé
et la descendance
de Noé,
sert à comprendre
d'où sont venus
ces peuples
et de manière
très historique.
Ce sont des bases
pour tous les rapports
historiques d'Israël
dans notre passage
de l'Ancien Testament.
Non seulement ça,
les questions généalogiques
sont très importantes
car la structure généalogique
est très répétitive.
En Génèles chapitre 4,
verset 17,
les descendants de Caen,
Caen connut sa femme,
elle conçut
enfantin Enoch
et depuis,
il bâtit une ville
et il appela
du nom de son fils
la ville Enoch.
Donc, à nouveau,
description des villes
qui auraient pu être
identifiables
historiquement parlant.
Mais c'est intéressant,
on voit cette structure
dans la première généalogie.
Quand on arrive
au chapitre 5,
verset 1 à 32,
nous avons
la généalogie d'Adam,
voici les livres
des générations,
ce qui est pris
toujours comme
très historique.
ensuite,
Genèse 10,
les descendants
de Noé,
regardez la phrase,
voici les générations
des fils de Noé.
Donc,
voici les livres
des générations,
voici les générations
et cela va se répéter
pour les descendants
des Sème
au chapitre 11,
voici les générations
des Sème.
Au chapitre 25,
les descendants
d'Ismaël,
voici les générations
d'Ismaël.
C'est-à-dire
que la phrase éologie,
la structure
de la phrase,
cette introduction
de la phrase
a un poids historique
très important
pour qu'on puisse
suivre les traces.
Et donc,
tout cela est connecté
depuis Adam lui-même.
Et donc,
on n'a pas
la possibilité
de chercher
de manière arbitraire
à suggérer
une interprétation
non littérale
d'un livre
qui est si renforcé
par les évidences
historiques.
Donc,
on aurait pu
aller jusqu'à Genèse 46
en passant par
plusieurs autres passages
qui répètent
cette structure
voici les générations.
C'est comme
un marquage du temps
et un marquage historique
pour nous rappeler
que Genèse
est très important
comme livre historique.
Non seulement
un marquage
important
et historique,
mais un marquage
qui nous montre
la fiabilité
historique
de la tradition
patriarcale.
Comment pouvons-nous,
comment pourrions-nous
nous fier
au récit
de Genèse
comme quelque chose
d'historique
et littéral ?
On aurait pu dire
« Ok,
si quelqu'un
aurait pu vivre
proche d'Adam,
j'aurais pu croire
car Adam était
les premiers
après la création
des dieux. »
Et c'est intéressant
quand on va
contempler
ces premiers hommes
qui n'étaient pas
si impactés
encore par la chute
et leur vie
était presque
la vie des mille ans
pour une bonne majorité,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que les pères
de Noé
ont vécu
avec Adam.
C'est très intéressant.
Adam,
Cainan,
Mahalael,
Jared,
Enoch,
Mithuzala,
Lamech,
père de Noé
et Noé.
Donc Lamech
a vécu
avec Adam.
Il a pu entendre
l'histoire
de la création,
de comment
étaient les choses
au début.
Et donc
Noé lui-même
a vécu
avec l'arrière
petit-fils,
petit-enfant
d'Adam,
Cainan.
Celui qui était
la quatrième génération
depuis Adam
vivait avec Noé
de sa famille.
Donc c'est très important
pour nous
de considérer
cette fiabilité
par rapport
à l'importance
historique
et généalogique.
Mais c'est aussi
intéressant
de considérer
que Moïse
qui est en train
d'écrire
la Pentateuch,
il a écouté
des quilles lui-même
directement
de la part des dieux.
Une bonne portion
il aurait pu
avoir reçu
par la tradition
qui était déjà
très fiable
mais c'est clair
que Dieu
lui parlait.
Donc
septième argument
non seulement
les évidences
historiques
internes
à Genèse
mais aussi
les autorités
bibliques
qui prennent
ces textes
comme historiques.
Donc si on prend
l'Ancien Testament
donc Moïse lui-même
avec la Pentateuch
qui est à la base
mais les livres
des chroniques
commencent
les premiers chapitres
en disant
Adam, Seth,
Enos, etc.
donc les livres
des chroniques
c'est les livres
historiques
quelque part
les plus importants
de l'histoire
d'Israël.
C'est les livres
consacrés
à l'histoire
d'Israël.
Et il commence
avec Adam,
Seth,
Enos, etc.
Avec la généalogie
littérale
de Genèse.
C'est important
de remarquer
comment presque
tous les livres
de l'Ancien Testament
font au moins
une référence
à Genèse
comme étant
littéral.
Donc on n'aura pas
le temps
de vous citer
tous les passages
mais c'est très important
et d'ailleurs
les déluges
sont repris
à plusieurs reprises
comme littéral.
Ensuite,
Dieu lui-même,
donc là quand on entend
Exode 20,
je pense que c'est
les textes principaux
à cet égard.
Exode 20,
pardon,
chapitre 20,
verset 8 à 11
et il dit
car en six jours
l'Éternel,
verset 11,
a fait les cieux
et la terre
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui dit.
Donc c'est l'interprétation
de Dieu lui-même
sur Genèse.
Et ça résonne énormément
avec Genèse chapitre 1,
verset 1,
au commencement
Dieu créa
les cieux et la terre.
La terre était en formé vide
et l'esprit des dieux
comment vous dites en français ?
C'est mauvais
au-dessus des eaux.
Ok ?
Et donc c'est intéressant
pourquoi on ne peut pas
croire à une différence
entre les cieux
et les cieux
car l'écho
de cette déclaration
au commencement
Dieu créa
les cieux
et la terre
et ensuite
si on veut suggérer
un cataclysme
et des airs
etc.
pour après voir
comment Dieu va former
ou réformer les choses
la réalité
c'est qu'ici
au verset 11
Dieu prend l'ensemble
comme en séparable
il va dire
car en six jours
l'éternel a fait
les cieux
et la terre
et la mer
et tout ce qui est contenu.
Vous voyez comment
ce texte rend impossible
inflexible
une séparation
entre verset 1 et 2
car ici
il est en train
de condenser
dans les six jours
la même déclaration
initiale
au commencement
Dieu fait
les cieux
et la terre
et donc ici
car en six jours
Dieu l'éternel
a fait les cieux
et la terre
et la mer
et tout ce qui est contenu
et il s'est reposé
les septième jour
c'est pourquoi
l'éternel a béni
les jours
de repos
et l'a sanctifié.
Donc
impossibilité
de ne pas traiter
comme littéral.
Exode
c'est plus ou moins
la répétition
de la même chose
car en six jours
l'éternel
a fait les cieux
et la terre
et le septième jour
il a cessé son œuvre
et il s'est reposé.
Donc
déjà
la base
pour l'observation
d'un jour littéral
des repos
et d'adoration
est
la référence
à un jour littéral
à la création
ça devrait suffire
mais davantage
la déclaration
en six jours
l'a fait les cieux
et la terre
pour faire un écho
presque littéral
du verset 1
de Genèse.
Quand on arrive
au Nouveau Testament
les généalogies
du Christ
sont les premières choses
mises en évidence
dans les évangiles
de Luc et Matthieu
et donc ça remonte
à chaque fois
à les traitements
historiques
de Genèse
et notamment
jusqu'à Adam
et ensuite
Christ lui-même
il y a
plein de références
du Christ
qui a pris Genèse
pour littéral
et notamment
Genèse chapitre 1
avec la création
de l'homme
et de la femme
donc la question
du divorce
il répond
n'aviez-vous pas
Luc
les créateurs
dès les commencements
fit l'homme
et la femme
et qu'il dit
c'est pourquoi
l'homme qui t'aidera
son père et sa mère
s'attachera à sa femme
et les deux
deviendront
une seule chair
le Christ prend
pour littéral
il interprète
littéralement
Genèse
Marc 10
pour faire
les parallèles
de la même occasion
ok
et ensuite
Luc 11
et 51
c'est très intéressant
afin que cette génération
reçoive la condamnation
du sang
de tous les prophètes
versés
depuis la fondation
du monde
attention
quand est-ce que
le monde a eu
sa fondation
sans séparation
entre fondation
du monde
plus
air
évolution
homme
non
c'est depuis
la fondation
du monde
c'est-à-dire
très proche
de l'origine
de toutes les choses
très proche
du début
du commencement
de toute la terre
de la fondation
du monde
depuis le sang
d'Abel
jusqu'au sang
des Achari
donc Abel
vivait
très proche
de la fondation
du monde
vous êtes avec moi
en possibilité
d'apprêtation
des airs
Matthieu 24
37 à 39
ce qui arriva
du temps
de Noé
arrivera
de même
à l'avènement
du fils de l'homme
car dans les jours
qui précédaient
les déluges
les hommes mangeaient
et bouvaient
se mariaient
et se donnaient
en mariage
jusqu'au jour
de Noé
entra dans l'arche
et il naissait
de terre
de rien
jusqu'à ce que
les déluges
viennent
et les emportent
tous
donc c'est Christ
lui-même
qui interprète
l'épisode
du déluge
universel
comme en étant
littéral
je ne sais pas
quelle a difficulté
de croire
dans la création
du monde
en six jours
vous allez vous mettre
en beaucoup
des difficultés
aussi
par d'autres passages
bibliques
qui sont évidemment
traités comme historiques
dans la parole
des dieux
les autres auteurs
du nouveau testament
donc on a plein de passages
aussi
Adam était formé
les premiers
ensuite Ève
1 Timothée 2
Hébreu 11
par la fin
en reconnaissant
que les mondes
étaient formés
par la parole
des dieux
acte 17
ça c'est intéressant
il a fait
que tous les hommes
sortis dans
l'homme
habitent
toute la surface
de la terre
ayant déterminé
les temps fixés
et les limites
de leur demeure
donc Paul
qui prêche
en Athènes
Jude
c'est ces gens-là
qui énoche
les septièmes
après Adam
qu'il prend aussi
des manières littérales
Apocalypse
et les grands dragons
les serpents anciens
appelaient les diables
et Satan
celui qui séduit
le monde entier
fut précipité sur terre
et ses anges
furent précipités
avec lui
donc les grands dragons
les serpents anciens
est traité
comme un personnage
littéral
et historique
je pense que
sur ces points
c'est très important
de juste faire
un parenthèse
comment Genèse 1
à 6
sont pris par historique
de manière très claire
dans le Nouveau Testament
et particulièrement
la récourrence
des références
de la part du Christ
des pierres
des pôles
en plusieurs passages
qui évoquent
les jugements
des dieux
donc la force
par exemple
et la certitude
surtout Pierre
il fait la liaison
de ne pas ignorer
les jours du Seigneur
qui reviendra
de manière
indubitable
pour juger
à cause de cette présentation
et cette explication
des romans 5
et la ration
par un
les péchés rentrés
donc l'implication
littérale
théologique
par un
les péchés rentrés
par les nouvelles
Adam
nous allons avoir
les saluts
donc là
l'entrée du péché
du monde
et par les péchés
là
mort
l'impossibilité
de chercher
à expliquer
les extraits
géologiques
selon la mentalité
évolutionniste
qui veulent dater
les fossiles
comme ayant
des milliards d'années
c'est impossible
pour nous théologiquement
que les fossiles
existent
avant la chute
d'Adam
il n'y a pas
des morts
et donc
pour nous
les extraits
des fossiles
ne peuvent jamais
pointer envers
au-delà d'Adam
vous êtes avec moi
par les péchés
de la mort
et la certitude
d'un jugement futur
donc eux
ils veulent se clôturer
dans un système
fermé
où Dieu
n'intervient pas
et la réalité
c'est que Dieu
intervient
il est intervenu
surtout
par un jugement
global
qui était
la 20 première
de jugement final
et donc
c'est impossible
de se préparer
pour les retours
du Christ
sans prendre en considération
l'aspect littéral
de Noël
l'importance
non seulement
pour les saluts
par la représentativité
d'Adam
mais l'importance aussi
pour qu'on croit
dans les jugements à venir
et pour que l'Église
soit sécouée
envers ces jugements
donc c'est très important
pour nous
de considérer
cette réalité
de l'intervention divine
pour finir
j'aurais pu citer
je vais juste mentionner
je n'aurai pas le temps
de vous présenter
mais
j'ai par étape
de l'histoire
de l'Église
depuis la tradition juive
passant par les pères
de l'Église
passant par les Moyen-Âge
passant par la réforme
en présentant surtout
Calvin
et bien sûr Luther
et les réformateurs
et les puritans
la majorité massive
de la tradition
confessionnelle chrétienne
a toujours traité
Genèse
comme littérale
donc je vous ai présenté
des évidences internes
bibliques
et des évidences
théologiques importantes
et j'ai fini
avec l'histoire
de l'Église
et ce que nous allons
considérer
à partir
de la semaine prochaine
c'est l'autre partie
du comment
aujourd'hui c'était
les camps
et on va observer
un peu mieux
la beauté
et la gloire de Dieu
dans cette sagesse
révélée dans la suture
de la création
et nous allons qualifier
en fait
quelques caractéristiques
de la création
aujourd'hui mon objectif
c'était de vous démontrer
l'inflexibilité
de l'interprétation littérale
pour ce qui concerne
l'âge de la terre
et les moments
de la création
ok
internellement
par les méthodes
herménotiques
ou d'interprétation biblique
c'est le plus important
pour nous
à partir de là
dans d'autres occasions
je vais essayer
de vous montrer
comment
l'évidence même
scientifique
peut corroborer
et confirmer
cette vérité
pour nous
c'est vérité
c'est pas théorie
ok
donc qui peut prier
pour nous
pour conclure
c'est le plus important